I think we're at the end of a 300 year
run of a liberal vision of the world
however we want to call them and maybe
something called the modern and and I
think that vision is in some trouble not
predicting its demise not yet but it's
in some trouble now because in the last
30 years to this day since in the cold
war that liberals around the world have
pursued a rather extreme ideological
version of modern liberalism which
precludes and excludes other
possibilities both intellectually and
economically to the point where I think
the leader of the liberal world the
United States of course had committed
what Paul Kennedy's defined as Imperial
overreach both externally internally
externally it's it's gone too far and
try to impose its vision on the rest of
the world are so many countries to some
extent in some cases militarily to
rather disastrous consequences and
internally it's taken this vision of the
world which places the individual as the
autonomous basic unit of society at the
center of the universe internally it's
gone pretty far since the Reagan such a
revolution with the neoliberal economic
doctrine that has led to tremendous
inequality in developed countries that
are generating this backlash against the
liberal tradition both the liberal
tradition and end globalization itself
and these problems are not being solved
so so I think that's partially how I see
it on the outside from a non liberal
society
the trouble with with the liberal vision
what's the cause of the many crisis we
are facing I think that first of all I
agree that globalization is a main
driver for this angst this anxiety that
we have today in our societies I'm
speaking out more about the Western
society so Europe Americas
I think that was Sicily very much
aggravated by the financial crisis and
austerity policies and impact that it
had foresee in Europe a very specific
issue is this movement of refugees and
illegal migrants that has put a lot of
pressure in some societies that were not
used to deal with multiculturalism or
diversity or they thought that they had
enough of that so and that creates a
backlash so there are many causes there
is not a single cause and by the way I
think we should avoid easy
simplifications in fact that's one of
the one of the intellectual devices if I
may say so of populism the inconstant if
you get is to make these kind of
simplifications I do not agree that we
are in a worse position now than 30 or
40 years ago in fact you I think we are
in a better position now if you look at
Europe today okay we are not happy with
all the political systems and we are not
happy with all the government's but it's
certainly better than we have when you
get off of Europe and the totalitarian
communism it's much better
I mean situation in in Poland or or in
any central Eastern European country is
better from all points of view I mean
economically socially in literacy terms
in openness so I don't agree liberal
societies have these rulers these elites
that somehow take their legitimacy for
granted so they say we're legitimate
because we're liberal liberalism grants
us legitimacy doesn't matter no matter
what and you're illegitimate because
you're a liberal
therefore you know so that kind of
complacency I think
may defeat liberalism which will be
unfortunate I like to see a world where
there are many different ideas of how to
govern and and and but but I I mean that
would be the danger of liberal societies
I'm current unease party in the state
are not in danger of that because they
are constantly in this and have the
sense of crisis and how they deliver and
that's that's what I mean by legitimacy
[Applause]
what you wrest legitimacy on is on one
hand just an empirical question all
governments succeed only to the extent
that they deliver in some way but the
issue that you raised with with Taiwan I
think goes to the heart of a very
important problem and and that is if
there are millions of people who want to
govern themselves does nationalism
always Trump's self government well and
and and and that that seems to me or a
rather urgent matter especially since
the nationalism that would trump
self-government is that of a one-party
state well it depends and that's not a
question of I think the problems of
liberalism are evident but the fact that
liberalism or Western societies have
enormous problems and I come from a
country where we have a very very big
problem starting with the president you
know the fact that there were problems
doesn't legitimize any other form of
rule that's exactly my point the fact
that we have problems does only demise
you
you